ah
[Música]
mi primera pelea fue a los 14 años en
aquel entonces un compañero llamado
mario me volteaba prácticamente todos
los días yo era un adolescente flaco
tímido medio nerd al que le aterraba en
los golpes y por lo tanto cada vez que
me molestaba yo no hacía nada solamente
desviar la mirada y ya
pero un día algo cambió durante una
clase libre mario se puso frente a mí me
empezó a decir de cosas como lo usual yo
solo mira hacia otro lado y de un
momento para otro me metí un cabezazo
ya no pude más me levanté comenzamos a
forcejear todo el salón se puso
alrededor de nosotros y empezó a gritar
de cosas cuando de repente mario que era
más grande y más fuerte que yo me tiró
al piso y allí en el piso sentí una
furia una tristeza y una humillación
como las que nunca antes había
experimentado en mi vida
me levanté me metí un golpe en la nariz
otro en la boca y lo seguí golpeando
hasta acabar con las manos temblando y
manchadas de sangre y con cada golpe me
sentí tan fuerte tan bravo tan poderoso
que a la fecha recuerdo esa primera
pelea como uno de los momentos de mi
vida en que más me sentido como un
hombre
sentirse como un hombre varias veces en
talleres conferencias o terapia he hecho
la siguiente pregunta cuáles son los
momentos de tu vida en que más te has
sentido como un hombre y siempre he
obtenido una variedad interesante de
respuestas cuando traigo y miro al hogar
cuando doy una orden y se cumple cuando
gana una pelea cuando mis hijos me
atienden cuando abrazo a mi pareja por
la cintura y me siento grande fuerte
protectora cuando coqueteo con una mujer
atractiva y la pongo nerviosa cuando
tengo sexo rudo por horas entre otras el
punto en común de estas experiencias es
que todas son experiencias de poder el
poder de proveer el poder de dar órdenes
el poder de vencer un contra encargo el
poder de ser atendido el poder de
seducir el poder de proteger
a los hombres se nos enseña desde niños
que nuestro valor en tanto hombres
depende de que todo el tiempo tengamos
poder nuestros juegos suelen ser de
competencia porque hay que aprender a
dominar a los otros nos enseñan a
seducir conquistando como si las
personas que nos gustan fueran
territorios libres en espera ser
controlados
nos dicen que ahora somos los hombres de
la casa apenas falta nuestro padre
llegamos a la adolescencia casi todos
recibimos una variación del famoso los
hombres no lloran porque creemos que
demostrar vulnerabilidad es lo opuesto a
demostrar poder y como decimos cuando un
hombre no puede tener una erección
impotencia a través de esta educación
nos vuelven adictos a buscar
experiencias de poder en gran medida
porque quien es poderoso tiene
privilegios y la promesa del machismo es
que uno tú mereces esos privilegios solo
por ser hombre y dos si tienes
privilegios no vas a sufrir porque en
esta cultura machista quien no es hombre
o quien no es suficientemente hombre
sufre mucho
yo no quería pelear con mario pero era
la única manera que tenía de recuperar
cierto poder frente a todo el acoso que
sufrí cada uno de los días que estuve en
secundaria
pero porque mario me molestaba ay les da
un giro a la trama mario me molestaba
porque él también era burlado y mucho
peor que yo cuando él era niño tuvo un
accidente en el que perdió algunos dedos
de la mano todo el salón se burlaba de
él constantemente por eso molestarme era
una forma que tenía para recuperar el
poder que los otros compañeros le
quitaban al burlarse de él por ser un
hombre incompleto
los hombres tenemos tanta presión por
mantener el poder y nos enseñan de
tantas formas a buscar ya disfrutar su
sensación como si fuera una droga que su
falta se vuelve psicológicamente
intolerable lo que nos lleva en muchas
ocasiones a violentar nos o a violentar
otras personas con tal de probar que
somos hombres poderosos por poner
algunos ejemplos
una de cada tres mujeres sufrirá
violencia sexual por parte de un hombre
en algún momento de su vida y se piensa
que uno de cada seis hombres sufrirá
abuso sexual y digo se piensa porque es
muy difícil conocer las estadísticas
precisas por la vergüenza que supone
para un hombre reconocer que sufrió
abuso porque ocurren estas violencias en
gran medida por la experiencia de poder
que implica a dominar el cuerpo y la
sexualidad de otra persona los
accidentes de tráfico son la principal
causa de muerte de hombres jóvenes en el
mundo en gran medida porque los hombres
jóvenes suelen tomar más riesgos al
volante para demostrar su audacia los
hombres nos suicidamos más y tenemos más
infartos relacionados al estrés en parte
porque no hablamos de nuestra angustia
nuestra tristeza nuestras preocupaciones
porque eso significaría reconocer que no
somos omnipotentes sino que podemos ser
vulnerables como el resto de la
humanidad y de alguna manera nos hemos
comprado la idea de que todo esto es lo
normal
pero no tendría por qué hacerlo frente a
la gran crisis de violencia de parte de
hombres hacia mujeres personas el eje de
otros hombres y hacia sí mismos hay un
reclamo y petición urgente los hombres
tenemos que cuestionar nuestra
masculinidad hacernos responsables de
las violencias machistas que cometemos y
ejercemos y recibimos y construir nuevas
formas de ser hombre esta es una tarea
titánica y creo que un primer paso puede
ser entender cómo es que la educación
que recibimos por nuestro género nos
afectó profundamente y nos hizo crecer
con terror llenos de presión adictos al
poder incapaces de sentir y expresar
emociones porque eso es lo que está
detrás de muchos de nuestros dolores y
violencias en mi trabajo como terapeuta
me ha demostrado que cuando nos
preguntamos individual y colectivamente
por la relación que hemos tenido con el
poder y con su falta nuestras historias
de vida pueden suceder cosas increíbles
he visto a hombres con problemas de ira
incontrolable entender que ese enojo fue
un mecanismo de defensa que surgió en
una situación de falta de poder vivir en
la infancia y he visto que pueden sanar
esas heridas pedir perdón resarcir el
daño y aprender a vivir en paz y sin
violencia
he visto a hombres reconocer que
sufrieron abuso sexual después de años
de estar en silencio y entender que
haber sufrido esta experiencia de dolor
y falta de poder no significa que no
sean dignos de amor porque son dignos de
amor
he visto hombres profundamente
deprimidos recuperar poco a poco su
salud mental a través de reconciliarse
con su vulnerabilidad y aprender a
sentir y expresar emociones y de esta
manera volver a conectar con el sentido
de sus vidas y con el de las personas a
las que man
y me estoy viendo a mí mismo poco a poco
aprender a vivir sin tanta presión de
ser un hombre que en el fondo no quiero
hacer porque esa búsqueda permanente de
poder en todo momento simplemente no lo
vale no es un camino fácil pues implica
renunciar a muchas de las prácticas para
las que nos educaron y hay muchos
privilegios que ostentamos así como
hacer una revisión muy crítica y a veces
muy dura de la propia historia
pero creo profundamente que podemos
reeducarnos para aprender a hacer
hombres que permiten la ternura que
aprenden a cuidar a ser cuidados que se
reconcilian con su vulnerabilidad que
renuncian a la violencia que supone
asociar masculinidad con poder y que
finalmente son más felices podemos
hacerlo
el mundo nos lo está pidiendo
nos conviene y además ya no tenemos de
otra muchas gracias